I have three words that you might not
think would go together what's that
buttermilk
Dill
and cashews it is a recipe that makes a
Tangy tasty holiday snack stick around
Good Day Las Vegas
so you guys know that over the past week
or so we've been collecting your
favorite holiday recipes yes but this
week we're also sharing some of our own
so I'm sharing my recipe for what are
called buttermilk Dill cashews so those
are three words you probably normally
wouldn't think about together but the
the idea here is you've got your raw
cashews and for any kind of nut that has
coating on it the secret is egg white
so you put the egg white in a cup or
some kind of a container and you whisk
it up into a little bit of a froth and
then you add your powdered ingredients
which in this case some common stuff uh
garlic powder onion powder coriander
lime juice dill weed for sure and dry
mustard then you pour that into the
coffee cup and that's what you pour onto
the nuts and you mix them up
like that and then you pour them on a a
cookie pan with your spring okay okay
and that keeps them from what from
sticking or burning or what no that's
well the spray absolutely because you're
going to have the oven up in like 325
okay for about 10 minutes at a time you
want to make sure you store them because
you don't want the nuts to burn okay but
the idea is to make them crunchy and I
have samples for you guys here these are
the can we show them what they look like
absolutely and I'm going to show you
what these look like those are really
now I don't know if buttermilk powder
has gluten in it I don't think it does
okay so go ahead and try it anyway we're
gonna we're gonna just dive in it's
crunchy wow it's got a little Tang oh
because you're adding citric acid powder
which looks kind of weird but it is
available at Sprouts Citron acid powder
and buttermilk powder powder so we have
the recipe up on our website then we
want your recipe in the online good day
in Las Vegas holiday recipe cookbook
send it to Pitts p-i-x at
oh my gosh 8newsnow.com these are really
good so Nate I have a question just
right quick yeah what is it that I'm
getting right here can we come back to
us on camera right quick right here Tang
it's the citric acid is that what it is
and the dill it's good though but it's
almost like yeah it's Tangy explosion of
flavor that you'd never get from a wow
cashew exactly I love it don't let me
mirror bowl that big I mean the whole
recipe is online so check it out